welcome to this video playing lotus
flower from from Italy to like to play
the sleeve again let's see Tramon or
variation trying to play it in classic
old-fashioned hoping that we get asked
even in at least them or haven again we
don't get that a ski burning and I
actually would have known it a bit at
least I think night a 4 immediately is
better I'd okay but this is also online
it cannot take on you for because of
Queen deform this is important and I
intend to play Knight b6 of course hmm
Rudy I i really i really don't know the
opening of course hmm what is the move
here can I go see for yes you 45 yeah
see for you might play Bishop d6 and
then I'm not a member so it's not clear
how to save that
poopyhead interesting how to protect the
spawn area we don't want to play a slow
move here like a bishop a three or
something c4 bishop t6 yeah maybe I can
play a 456 f4 Queen 94 Queen default
yeah that's not very economical playing
this ambitious stuff and spending so
much time and at the end he is playing
something entirely different I can play
c5 now threatening a three before
winning the piece i can probably first
take here and then play c5a three before
yes some yeah what is he doing against
it the id-5 was very quickly played
not sure why I mean he had some time to
to think about it and this now looks
really bad okay goodnight be six sizes
better you know he takes pawn takes the
coming Roxy one roof c7 is just very
good and that can force this with before
next smooth yeah I have it I have the
Sun this move as well I think through
strengthening the idea a bit
hmm yeah there's there's no real reason
why I shouldn't take a sick son or is
there let's take it
yeah and I'm just going probably just
back with the bishop and then before be
five bishops if know where it's not
really not really on I can just retreat
here 95 Bishop c5 the the rookie say and
now I'm also threatening to take only
for winning the d7 bishop
I take him and play Bishop f4 is almost
winning but Bishop Bishop f4 immediately
Nets the exchange you know rook b6
Bishop c7 yeah that's okay just just
when they exchange him you don't like to
give up this okay and this is even worse
if you move the rocket a key for and d7
is gone black resigns John the id-5 was
really needing to two big problems and I
don't understand really why why you need
to play this so quickly I mean c4 is an
obviously committal move and what about
94 it's a bishop d6 of course this was
my first vote of what I was saying I was
intending to play f4 night eggs and c5
this was my idea or queen deform those
two moves and I'm not sure at all what
how to assess this position something
like this that's probably good for
blackness 95 yeah probably my idea
wasn't good i mean i can try this now
here so yeah it's not it's not entirely
idiotic my idea but is it good I don't
think so but this just leads into big
trouble I mean after this black is on
the verge of being lost i think im just
just having such a big edge on the
queenside
yeah and now does this is basically gone
just a pawn and a big Queen side plane
he absolutely needs to take your form d
5 is a strange decision I don't know
maybe did I did I play this wrong I
think I did I think you need to play
this first this first is Sir is right so
that after moves like Whoopi 8 you have
have some other options let's even see
for here I believe okay interesting but
he really shouldn't play d 5 and so
quickly yeah thanks for watching